foreign
did you know
that a crowd of New Yorkers once filled
a hall
with thousands more awaiting a word
outside
and that the police had to come and
forbid the selling of additional tickets
and that the New York Times used the
phrase a phrase not yet a cliche that
people were packed like sardines
and did you know that this frenzy was
all because people were desperate to
watch a woman walk in circles on Sawdust
the sport was pedestrianism
when watching people walk was America's
pastime
I won't get too deep into the story of
our pedestrian Ada Anderson and the
breathless New York Times articles about
her walk
2700 quarter miles in 2700 consecutive
quarter hours I bring up this long ago
event for a singular purpose
to question what you think you know
about why we watch sports
if people lost their minds watching
someone walk in circles
what can this teach us about the heart
of sports
understanding what compels us to watch
sports it's not just a thought
experiment although it is that
but it's more I could have tangible
effects
if we're willing to inspect what
actually spikes our heart rate and
pushes us to the edge of our seats
instead of just assuming we know we can
all collectively make the Sports World a
more Equitable place
I didn't say equal I said Equitable fair
even-handed just
often if you ask someone why they watch
sports they will tell you because they
want to watch The Best of the Best
anything else
isn't worth their time
this reasoning
it presents itself as biological
the men's Sprint champion
always a half second faster than the
women's Sprint champion
the men of the NBA most of them can jump
higher than the women of the WNBA and on
and on
if we passively accept this premise
that the only Sports worth watching are
those played at the Apex of humanity
then we have baked into our Sports World
a reason for Why women's sports don't
and can't
and won't matter
for example
call me when women can dunk
is a thing people have long said
yeah all right so we're dunking now
ah actually you know what call me when
women can do 360 dunks
2050 here on the line
yeah all right yep we're doing 360 dunks
now too
ah yeah all right yeah we'll call you
then
all right you get it
so let me lay out my theory for you
my theory about what actually compels us
to watch sports
I spent seven years as a columnist and
feature writer at ESPN
and I did shows like around the horn
outside the lines First Take
and we would always look at the sports
calendar
and try to pinpoint the moments when
women's sports would be big like really
big
and it was always the same two events
the Olympics then the World Cup then the
Olympics toss some tennis in there but
mostly the Olympics in the World Cup
and so we got to thinking what is it
about these two events what are the
common factors
that allows women's sports to transcend
for these fleeting moments because
even at the Olympics the men's swim
times are just a fraction of a second
faster than the women's these two events
have two crucial elements in common
Stakes and storylines
this is what burns at the center of
sports
in the Olympics we have all agreed to
Gold Medal matters
same with the World Cup
and now paired with this agreed upon
Stakes we also have at the Olympics in
the World Cup very obvious storyline
one person has a USA Jersey on
someone else has a different country's
Jersey on all right we've got agreed
upon Stakes we've got very obvious
storylines of course now we're gonna
have a commitment to even deeper
storytelling which is how we end up
teary-eyed after a three and a half
minute NBC vignette about a Romanian
gymnast yeah
yeah you have everything you need now
for the next two hours of competition in
Olympic gold medal is on the line
and you've got your storyline
Romanian gymnasts desperately overcoming
the odds
boom
story lines drive up the stakes
higher Stakes more story lines and on
and up we go
every so often a female athlete or a
team they will hit the Tipping Point
we understand their story lines we've
got the stakes
here I'm thanking Serena Williams Simone
biles Ronda Rousey
Megan rapino
right these are the outliers
and having representation matters
well what tends to happen is that these
handful of female athletes carry the
media burden for all of women's sports
not only that the media gets to say yeah
we checked that box we're good we uh we
did that thing we put so and so on the
cover like seven years ago we're good
what doesn't happen
is the pursuit of additional story lines
expanding the breadth of our
storytelling which is what is
continually happening on the men's side
all right when I worked at ESPN and I
would do a TV show
I was in the production room and I was
always pitching women's sports stories
it almost never worked
every once in a while it would work
and the thing about doing sports on TV
is that you are not actually an expert
at everything you're talking about
yeah
but you read you do your homework you
figure out a position
but this thing would happen when we
would do a women's sports segment
many of the other men on the segment
they didn't really do their homework
so they were kind of blah
then the segment would be kind of blah
there's actually a term for this it's
called gender Bland
and then the segment would end and the
producer would be like see this is why
we never do women's sports because
they're boring
when a men's segment fell flat the
problem was us we would redo it
all right come on do your homework pick
it up we're doing that again
when a segment on women's sports fell
flat the problem
was women's sports
this is a microcosm
for how this plays out across media
never finding the new angle never
finding the new story so what you do is
you rely on the millions of stories that
already exist
and you know what already exists every
men's sports story imaginable
the reality is that just existing in our
culture
you will know a dozen men's story lines
I mean these things are literally push
notified to your phone
or you're sitting behind someone on an
airplane and you can't help but see what
they're watching on ESPN or you're at a
bar or a doctor's office
and the talking heads are giving you the
latest NBA drama
in America
osmosis will have you knowing men's
sports storylines
and by the way
when men have a daughter and they
finally get women sports
what they're really saying is they
finally have a front row seat to the
stakes and the storylines
let's go back in time again
Philadelphia 1931.
the Philadelphia quick steppers an
all-black Women's Basketball team led by
a legend Inez Patterson
Patterson she knows a thing or two about
storylines she's ahead of her time
so she goes to the local all black
newspaper the Philadelphia Tribune and
she proposes a deal
sponsorship
storylines in exchange for naming rights
this may very well be the first naming
rights deal in history
the Philadelphia quick steppers become
the Philadelphia tribunes
and I bring this up because the very
next year 1932.
there's an inter-city rival the
Germantown Hornets with Oro Washington
very famous player
and they decide the two of them
Germantown the tribunes to play a
five-game series to determine the best
team in Philadelphia
remember
storylines was part of the deal
five game series goes to a fifth game
and this is how the Tribune writes about
the atmosphere in game 5 1932.
the cash customer's fan to Fever Heat by
the arter and closeness of combat gave
Outlet to all kinds of riotous impulses
all right this may not sound familiar
yet but our girl Ada Anderson all right
1879 the New York Times writes about her
walk her walk many women were seen to
faint in the dense crowd but as they
could not be carried out it is not known
what became of them
God damn
people loved ladies sports right
I mean
[Applause]
who knew
well wherever you find compelling story
lines and agreed upon Stakes
you will find people on the edge of
their seat
no matter the vertical leap of the
participant
so
who tells the story lines of women's
sports today
many of you will know the statistic I'm
about to put up University of Southern
California Purdue University released in
2021 studying the year 2019 in sports
media coverage
of all the minutes of ESPN SportsCenter
in 2019
5.1 percent of them given to women's
sports
you know what's really sad about this
number
is that it's not even as high as it
looks because 2019 was a women's world
cup year
what happens when you take out the
Women's World Cup minutes
3.5 percent
of all of the minutes of SportsCenter
given to women's sports
now what if I told you that number is
even higher than it seems
because what mostly makes up that number
is like a game recap a quick highlight
we call these one and duns
there is nothing to think about there's
no follow-up
it is a storyline for a reason because a
line keeps going
a game recap is not a storyline
what drives interest in sports
are the heroes and the villains and the
were they paid too much and should that
coach be fired something to really sink
your teeth into and to stake a position
on
do you know that ESPN has had the rights
to the WNBA all 26 years of the League's
existence
and in that time not one Studio show was
ever made to introduce people to these
storylines of the WNBA
people will tell you that number
reflects consumer demand
but that number reflects one thing
that number
who can want more of something they have
never been given
and how can we believe we want more of
something if the reasons for not wanting
it
are biological
that feels pathological
remember Ada Anderson
remember the Philadelphia tributes the
cash customers fanned to Fever Heat
and why did they fan to Fever Heat
because our Collective love of sport is
deep and it's human and it's driven by
deep and human motivations
the physical expression of athleticism
is just one element of the equation but
somehow for reasons we know it has been
elevated Above All Else
to justify our current model
this is a model built
without vision
meant to reluctantly provide women a
small place
but never
not really a chance
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]